hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne ja endlich mache ich wieder
diese Begrüßung wer diesen Kanal zum
ersten Mal sieht ich mache jedes Mal
diese Begrüßung und seit ich es nicht
mehr mache höre ich regelmäßig von
meinen Zuschauern das hier ist doch
vermissen also hier noch mal bitte schön
was soll ich sagen ich habe es wieder
getan ich möchte maskworld eine zweite
Chance geben nach meinem letzten
Halloween Mystery Unboxing war ich ja
nicht so überzeugt
auf gar keinen Fall liegt vielleicht an
ein paar Haaren und
komische 20 € bekommen und dann glaube
ich nicht dass die so versaut ist dafür
habe ich dieses mal tiefer in die Tasche
gegriffen und zwar haben wir ausgegeben
39,99 für die Mystery damenkostümen Box
dieses Mal nicht sexy da bin ich
gespannt was sie unter nicht sexy
verstehen und dann habe ich mich so
richtig nicht lumpen lassen und habe
noch mal für
24,99 € eine Mystery Box mit Make-up und
SFX geholt da freue ich mich echt drauf
denn so Kunstblut und Latex fürs Gesicht
kann man immer gebrauchen wird
eigentlich nicht so schnell schlecht
vielleicht schon aber naja es ist auf
jeden Fall Zeug was universelle
einsetzbar ist aus meinem letzten
Unboxing habe ich gelernt dass es nicht
so viel Sinn macht da jetzt die Preise
nachzuschauen weil es die meisten
Kostüme gar nicht mehr wirklich gibt
oder sie einfach so zerstreut und nicht
vollständig sind dass ich weiß gar nicht
was ich davon verlangen sollte
ich gucke einfach mal ob es sich für den
Preis den nicht bezahlt habe lohnt ob es
sich gut anfühlt oder ob es wieder
einfach ein eklige Ekel ekel-wert sein
wird
wir beginnen mit den Kostümen die Box
ist dieses Mal sauber ich kann sie
berühren ohne dass meine Hände staubig
sind großes Plus an dieser Stelle oh
mein Gott wie groß sind meine Daumen aus
ein Messer ein Messer ein Messer ich
glaube das wird jetzt hier richtig was
schreibt mir gerne als was Ihr euch
dieses Jahr verkleidet oder ob ihr
Halloween überhaupt feiert oh oh
hier sind richtig verpackte Kostüme drin
die paar Euro mehr lohnen sich ich hol
einfach mal raus dieses Kostüm heißt
Youtuber thumbnail
es ist einfach ein cozygold Fisch okay
love it ich ziehe es an da da da ist gar
nicht richtig scharf gestellt so jetzt
wo sind die Augen das einzige Problem
von diesem Kostüm das ja das fällt halt
so runter ne und sorry ich würde eher
sagen das ist sexy ich habe so gesehen
ich habe
zehn von zehn obwohl ein Punkt Abzug
weil die Kapuze echt die fällt halt so
runter was Sinn macht aber ich sehe
nichts mist das ist halt auch voll
praktisch weil das richtig warm ist es
ist zwar eine l aber es kann auch sein
dass ich mittlerweile auch einfach eine
XL geworden bin aber es ist das perfekte
man feiert halt draußen oder ist es das
perfekte Kostüm für um die Häuser ziehen
gehst du halt so die Straße entlang die
Straße sehe ich ja noch dann gehst du so
mit deiner Tüte und gehst du zur Tür und
sag süße sonst gibt's saures und dann
geht's wieder runter und du siehst alles
okay auch zum nächsten Kostüm ehrlich
gesagt fühle ich mich gerade ein
bisschen verarscht das war wirklich
nicht schlecht auf zum nächsten oh mein
Gott yes hey das sieht aber auch noch
voll in Ordnung aus bei den anderen hat
man richtig gesehen dass das so B-Ware
war und ja halt nicht mehr vollständig
irgendwas war so ein bisschen kaputt ich
gehe jetzt Heidi Klum ist sogar verpackt
diese Perücke hat ein bisschen Spliss
und mal hier brechen Haare ab das ist ja
wohl das beste überhaupt okay wie kriege
ich muss meine Haare zum Zopf finden
willkommen bei meiner Schreck
Transformation ich habe noch dieses Jahr
zu Timo gesagt dass ich eigentlich voll
lustig fände wenn wir als Shrek und
Fiona gehen würden und jetzt ist da
einfach so ein Kostüm drin aber ich
verstehe es nicht weil die vollständig
sind und sauber und was ist hier los
[Musik]
ich brauche nur Naomi die mir bei der
Perücke hilfe ich kann ich ja meine
Perücken nicht aus okay ich ziehe jetzt
noch das Kleid an
extrem
hallo
das ist mega geil also ich musste noch
die Haare ein bisschen besser hinkriegen
ne also hier gucken meine Hunde raus
wenn ich dann noch mein Gesicht grün
anmale vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Dampfbügeln das kann man auch noch mal
machen und wenn man nächstes Jahr
einfach mal als Prinzessin gehen möchte
damit man halt nur deswegen zehn von
zehn bin schockiert ich bin schockiert
ist das geil jetzt habe ich richtig Lust
nein ich bin so verwirrt ich kann es
euch nicht beschreiben es hat sogar eine
Bügel das hat hier so Knöpfe
Tom die wollen mich doch verarschen bei
dem letzten Paket haben wir quasi Müll
gehabt nee nee nee nee nee nee nee das
kann ich anziehen und jetzt hat man
solche Kostüme da drin hatte ich so Pech
mit meiner letzten Mystery Box war das
einfach so eine Niete und das ist jetzt
so irgendwas okay ich glaube
ich Halloween Schnapper meines Lebens
gemacht es hat ein Reisverschluss
natürlich hat sie Reißverschluss klar es
ja natürlich hat auch noch die original
Öhrchen hier sind noch die Öhrchen laber
mich nicht voll okay das muss ich
anziehen
ich fühle mich verarscht guckt euch mal
dieses Kostüm an
ein Unterrock ein einzelnen Unterrock
und wisst ihr warum ist glaube ich da
drin ist weil hier kann man das so an
den Fingern machen und hier ist das
kaputt das ist in zwei Sekunden genäht
das einzige was ich nicht verstehe das
sind dieses Mal l-kostüme und es ist mir
so eng dass es schon deprimiert ist
[Musik]
aber kommt dann noch hier diese cuten
Demon Ohren es ist so ein cooles Kleid
dafür zahlt man doch sonst 70 € oder so
das ist so ein richtiges Halloween
Kostüm okay ich höre jetzt mal auf das
Schuck zu sein ehrlich Bewertung Arme
ein bisschen eng aber ich habe auch
gerade meine Tage es kann sein dass ich
ein bisschen Wasser angelagert habe und
ein paar Tagen ist es dann so Timo sagt
auch zehn von zehn ist das einzige was
mich echt überrascht ist meine Arme weil
ich dachte jetzt nicht dass ich so krass
an den Arm zugenommen habe aber wenn der
L mir so eng ist ich bin ja keine XL
also normalerweise nicht schon sehr
komisch okay ähm das war schon Kostüm
Nummer 3 ich bin gespannt auf Kostüm
Nummer vier okay die Nummer vier ja klar
ein Retro Kleid okay
wir sind uns einig das ist das
schwächste Kostüm also es ist auch cool
und ich glaube ich werde es auch für
andere Sachen gebrauchen können mal für
seine eighties Mottoparty und so aber
gegen die anderen ist das jetzt
natürlich nicht also kann überhaupt
nicht mithalten aber ist auch gut sind
Oma Vibes habe ich hier ne
also ich bin im Mist ich bin richtig
in Halloween geile Kostüme Rausch 39,99
das war der Deal meines Lebens ich habe
drei geile Kostüme und ein Oma Kleid
bekommen bei dem letzten war der
Warenwert 159 € und 19,99 haben wir
bezahlen bei diesem ist der Warenwert
199 € wir haben 39,99 € bezahlt also ja
das hat sich definitiv mehr gelohnt und
jetzt checken wir noch die FSX
SFX
119 € soll der Warenwert von den SFX
Sachen sein du das lasse ich mir nicht
zweimal sagen ein Schnapper
endlich habe ich einen
Ärmel für meine nicht tätowierten Armen
hey ist gar nicht mal so schlecht okay
ich muss mir ganz kurz meine normalen
Klamotten anziehen ich kann mich in
diesem Kleid nicht sehen alles Gute so
ähm ja ich dachte aber auch nicht zu
dick sein ich werde es gebrauchen können
ich weiß dass man was ist denn heute los
ich freue mich und jetzt bin ich voll
tätowiert na was willst Du wissen aber
was ist gruseligste an diesem Video ist
meine grauen Haare die ich hier vorne so
bisschen raus gucken
ich will aber nur sagen die Tür ist auch
wieder ordentlich bevor ich so viel Zeug
drin
ich glaube es nicht die hat sich Timo
gerade gekauft hat die sich jetzt jemand
schon mal in den Mund gesteckt so
Vampirzähne Klone the dark ganz wichtig
also die sehen neu aus seht ihr dass ich
eh von Natur aus so 14 habe das schon
funktioniert Perlen rein und dann macht
man sich das in den Zahn oder macht man
sich das da so hinten ran das meine ich
mit kann man ganz ganz lang gebrauchen
ne auch geil aber ähm also was soll das
Piercing da am Zahn dann hat man so
richtig eklige Zähne mit Zahn
anpassungsmasse habt ihr sowas mal auf
einer Halloween Party getragen weil ich
kann mir auch nicht vorstellen dass man
dann irgendwie noch trinken und essen
kann man so ein Gebiss drin hat
natürlich kurz zu sagen ich will Sloty
Halloween ich brauche was was cute ist
und sexy das hat Timo auch ich wusste es
ich wusste dass Timo lieber nichts
kaufen soll weil ich nicht wusste was
hier drin sein wird ey das hat Timo
wirklich das und das liegt bei Timo auf
dem Schreibtisch Timo
rate mal was in meiner Mystery Box drin
war
oh nee hast du dafür ausgegeben
das ist original genau das was ich mir
gekauft habe ach nee
9,99 €
bezahlt und was kostet Horror Haut und
Horror Haut Effekt Make-up 6,99 okay als
nächstes haben wir scary Skin da drin
auch
originalverpackt meint ihr euch das
Gesicht grün an dann macht ihr das da
drauf und danach sieht es dann so
zusammen dich und so aus da könnt ihr
z.B als Frankenstein oder Gesicht machen
oder als Hexe passt das cool das sind
eben Ohren mit schweinsöhrchen gemischt
hier kann man die so dann festmachen und
so zuschneiden und dann kleben die sehen
auch toll aus wie laut er sein kann auch
geil vielleicht mache ich auf meine
Halloween Party hier so eine kleine SFX
Station und dann kann ich jedem was dran
machen
war ja klar ne als nächstes haben wir
gelb orangene Kontaktlinsen die ist so
ja so ein bisschen krank aussehen ne
vielleicht mache ich mir dieses Jahr
aber hier rein eigentlich finde ich das
ja cool aber ich habe immer Probleme die
danach rauszukriegen und ich habe die
Technik einfach nicht drauf ich war
schon mal beim Optiker und der hat das
sogar mit mir geübt und als ich dann zu
Hause war bin ich so in Panik verfallen
als die dann nicht rausbekommen habe vor
allem sind sie perfekt hier für die für
das teufelst du dann hast du so gelb
auch rote Augen Leute diese Tüte ist
immer noch voll nice Brandwunden also da
gibt's so ein Töpfchen und dann kann man
sich Brandwunden machen ah das sieht
toll aus hautfreundlich und ergiebig ah
das kann man auch zusammen verwenden
erstmal mit der Latexmilch und dann mit
den Brandwunden zusammen und dann hat
man so richtig so aufgekratzt und
aufgeplatzt und blutig und schön ja auch
sogar eine Maske haben die noch so im
hintersten zeigen von anderen gedacht
machen wir auch noch rein kann ich
gleich jetzt Horror Clown gehen boah die
ist wirklich gruselig Maske Gold ist ja
eigentlich bekannt für seine Masken ne
der jetzt
verkauft als Masken verkauft
oh nein oh ich wusste es ich wusste es
fast hättet ihr gerade gesehen dass
meine Wimpern nicht echt sind
das habe ich sogar schon mal gekauft
Zombie blutspray Blut zum Sprühen aber
bei dem Spray muss man so vorsichtig
sein weil wenn man das drauf sprüht das
spritzt so richtig stark und ich habe
das mal im Badezimmer benutzt das ist
alles an die Wand gegangen kann man
gebrauchen an Halloween noch einen
zwei in diesem Video habe ich auch
wieder Kelly Koffer Vibes aber nicht
wegen den Latexhandschuh dich wegen Ekel
anziehen muss sondern weil hier einfach
Schätze drin sind ja
die ist mir zu
eklig als Deko auf unserer Party
aufhängt und ist das für eine Maske
klasse super die kann man immer
gebrauchen auch super eine Schnittwunde
so könnt ihr sie anbringen Hammer oh das
kann ich mir vorstellen dass ich mir
auch egal was ich mache ich habe auch
überlegt als Schneewittchen zu gehen
aber jetzt habe ich ja die besten
Kostüme also ich glaube ich werde als
Vampir Braut gehen das ist einfach so
cool mit dem ganzen Blut und den Zehen
und sowas was wir haben aber wenn ich
jetzt Schneewittchen oder so gehe dann
mache ich mir auf jeden Fall hier so oh
das ist schon das letzte
wir sind mir ein bisschen es ist kaputt
oder ist also die sind mir ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen zu eklig guckt euch
mal das an das sieht so richtig BÄM
kleiner Tipp wenn ihr dieses Jahr auf
eine Halloween Party geht und ihr seid
zum Beispiel Single und wollt jemand
kennenlernen auch wenn das cool ist
macht es nicht ich gebe euch gerne ein
Fazit ich weiß jetzt nicht ob genau der
Warenwert der angegeben ist erreicht
wurde es interessiert mich auch nicht
weil ehrlich gesagt hier so viel cooles
Halloween Zeug drin ist und für 29,99
hätte ich das alles niemals im Laden
bekommen und dann noch Masken was ganz
geil ist wenn ich eine Halloween Party
veranstalte und jemand ohne Kostüm
kommen soll ich jetzt eine Maske ja das
einzige was ich nicht mag sind diese
aber
hast du dein Tattoo an nee ich bin happy
gute Sachen
gruseliger und damit wünsche ich euch
happy Halloween
und ja nächstes Mal gibt's wieder ein
Adventskalender auspack Video okay sorry
dass ich auch mal was anderes machen
möchte tschüssi
[Musik]